hi good evening members and welcome to
the review committee meeting um
before we start the meeting proper i
would like to do the emergency
evacuation announcement can i apologize
for my glasses i'm just trying them out
they're very focal so
if i lose my way it's because of the
glasses
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the hall entrance doors
turn right walk straight past the
canteen and through the external doors
on the right and out to the car park
which is our assembly point
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings
please do not return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
would you please switch your mobiles off
or turn them on to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you before speaking there's microphones
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio
recording please where possible
assist in passing microphones to each
other and use the hand gel and
antibacterial wipes on the tables if you
do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands and for
for and then against recommendations
those abstaining from voting will be
noted by officers
so agenda item one is apologies for
absence and we've had one apology from
councillor mrs pavlin
agenda item two substitute members there
is no substitute members
agenda item three non-members attending
uh councillor simon woodson and
councillor simon smith are in attendance
the gender item four is the minutes of
the meeting held on the fifth of october
2020 sorry 2021
are the minutes agreed members
okay thank you we agreed
agenda item 5 is to receive
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest members
okay no no
okay
moving on to agenda item 6 which is the
2021 stroke 22 mid treasury management
review
naomi lucas the assistant director of
resources will introduce the report and
council simon smith the whole portfolio
holder for financial services is also an
attendance for this item
so
naomi would you like to present the
report please
thank you chair
um
yeah the purpose of this report is to
provide an update of the council's
treasury management activity for the
period first of april 2021 to the 30th
of september 2021
in accordance with the council's
treasury management policy and good
practice in treasury management
it's recommended that the review
committee notes the contents of the
report and provides any comments or
questions it may wish to before it's
presented to full council for approval
next week on the 7th of december
the council
has adopted sitfa's code of practice on
treasury management and the requirement
of this is to produce a mid-year review
to look at the authority's performance
in line with the strategy which was
approved by this committee in february
so the mid-year report as i say has been
prepared in compliance with that code
and i'll just run you through the um
briefly through the main sections of the
report
which include an economic update for the
financial year to date provided by our
treasury advisors link
and also a review of
our compliance against the strategy
including our capital expenditure
and indicators a review of our
investment portfolio a review of our
borrowing strategy and a review of our
compliance with our treasury and
prudential limits
so that's
paragraph three of the report which is
on
page 6.2
um
we provide a brief economic update
of the
current situation
which essentially sets out the
monetary policies
committee's
latest um
uh sort of policy in terms of their
interest rate setting and members will
note that the bank rate is unchanged
currently at 0.1 percent which has been
up for
a number of months now
it was expected that that may rise um
the last time they met but it was held
at that at that level um our treasury
advisors are now advising that they
think it will rise to 0.25 in december
and then further to 0.5 percent in june
but obviously that's only a forecast at
this stage
there's obviously a number of
significant risks to the forecast um
including the ongoing impact of covert
19
and those risks are summarized at
paragraph 3.6
so in terms of the council's own
activity in the year to date
at paragraph 5 members will note the
capital expenditure that the council has
incurred
against the original budgetary estimates
so at the start of the financial year we
were forecasting that we would spend
around 3.6 million on capital
expenditure that current forecast has
now been revised down to just under 1.5
million
um and the main reason for that is the
um
pause or and um
review of the um
council's assets
delivery program um which is now
profiled to um occur slightly later than
originally envisaged so the one point
just under 1.5 million which was
due to be funded from the hardsoft
infrastructure reserve
um is now not forecast to be spent in
this financial year so that's the major
driver of the reduction in the capital
expenditure for this year but members
will note the other
means of financing the capital
expenditure which is also set out in the
table
in terms of the council's borrowings um
strategy members will note that um that
we've not currently approved use of any
external borrowing so the council's
underlying need to borrow as shown in
the um capital financing requirement
table at 5.3
is on is unchanged
so moving on to section six of the
report which sets out the council's
investment portfolio
members will note that we started the
year with 17 million pounds of
investment placed
during the first six months of the year
we've placed another 40 million but also
withdrawn 35 million which leaves us
with a closing balance of 22 million
pounds
invested and on top of that we have just
over 1.5 million in our current account
all these figures are at the end of
september of this year
so
members can also see the the way that
that
those balances have changed throughout
that six months and you'll note there's
a spike at the beginning of the year
when we were given some additional
covered monies for
businesses to distribute
and then the balance has
fluctuated slightly but remained roughly
constant since that point
at table 6.4 you can note the
the breakdown of where our monies were
invested
as at the 30th of september
the table um shows the breakdown of the
investments but also
the um interest rate that was achievable
on those which was previously requested
by members of this committee
and just to note that we've achieved um
interest returns of just over 12 000
pounds for the first six months of the
year
so we're forecasting um to make just um
over 25 000 by the end of the year we
didn't actually budget anything for
interest for this financial year because
the interest rates were so low at the
start of the year
but yeah we have had slightly higher
balances than we originally forecast
you can see from the investment
performance table that our performance
on our investments has exceeded the
benchmark returns across
the different categories of investment
duration
so finally i just want to confirm that
the council has complied with its own
treasury management strategy and there's
no breaches to report um
for the first six months of the year
so
at this point i would just
yeah i'd like to recommend the contents
of the report and ask if members have
any further questions thank you
thank you
um
councillor dre you're indicating that
you have questions
so
thank you chairman
um gemma my questions relate to a
paragraph 5.1
on page 6.4
um we've had an explanation this evening
regards to the drop in the forecast for
the hard soft infrastructure reserve
but i wonder if there's an explanation
as to the drop for the capital finance
reserve
um which has gone from one one two six
three down to eight five four
also um chairman um i don't like an
update in relation to the potential
future income from new homes bonus
and or its replacement if any
and also
i'd like details full details if
possible of all outstanding
and potential 106 agreement income for
all beneficiaries
and the expiry dates for the same
obviously the potential income from
106's is fairly substantial i would
suggest thank you chairman
thank you
naomi can you answer those questions
please
thank you chair yeah i'll do my best um
so i just wanted to clarify with
relation to the first point in terms of
their capital expenditure figures
um they're not actually the total sort
of balances of those reserves they're
just the planned use of those reserves
in year
so as i mentioned yeah as you said the
hydrosoft infrastructure reserve there's
a change in the forecast in terms of how
we use that for this year the capital
finance reserve
um again there's a reduction in what
we're planning to use from that reserve
that's not necessarily the total balance
that is available but in terms of um how
we fund our capital program we basically
um yeah look at what um
specific funding streams we have
available um so for example with the
disabled facilities grant we know we
have a specific grant available to fund
that expenditure the capital finance
reserve is basically used as our kind of
pool of monies which are available to
fund any kind of capital expenditure so
because the overall forecast
in capital spend has decreased so
correspondingly the call on the capital
financing reserve has also decreased in
year so i hope that answers that one um
in terms of the new homes bonus
um yeah there was a consultation on that
earlier in the financial year which
closed in february and there has been
very little um in the way of clarity
from government around what they intend
to do with the future of that scheme but
we are hopeful that when they announce
the provisional finance settlement in
december there will be details of
whether that scheme will continue or
whether a replacement scheme will be put
in put in place for that
and then finally in relation to the
section 106 monies
um i if i may i'd just like to point you
to um
a report which was taken to the
council's executive in july
july 22nd um so that's there was a
specific um
lee a detailed report setting out all
the available section 106 monies and
their planned use and that's intended to
be a regular report so that information
is out in the public domain and
available and seamless if you would like
to look at that and if you've obviously
got any follow-up questions then i'm
happy to try and answer them outside the
meeting
thank you and thank you chairman i shall
look at that report
councillor mrs
thank you mr mason he's gone off
i'm good with mics
thank you mr chairman now we've got the
technology sorted
um there seems to be an echo
just a couple of quick questions
um i do thank the officer for including
the interest rate because it does
actually give us
a better view on
how our money is
being
invested
the one other bit of information i'd
like i mean the money prime market and
incident markets are obvious but we've
got two 95-day accounts there they could
have been 95 days
from the first to september 30th of
september or to the 1st of october so is
it possible do you have the information
of when that 95 days started
um
it's basically a rolling 95. it's a role
period yeah yeah okay so it's 95 day
notice accounting not a 95 day account
there is a there is a difference okay
thank you that clarification so they're
both
um
95 day notice accounts
yes yes thank you thank you that's fine
that answers the question thank you
councillor wilkinson
thank you
i'm afraid i'm going to ask you a
question that i must apologize that you
work for an organization where most
members come from a background where we
don't understand the stuff you do
so please forgive me um i didn't realize
that the council had investments so for
the benefit of myself we've only been on
the council two and a half years and
maybe some of the other members could
you just explain to me um
what the council invests money in how we
invest i didn't realize we had that sort
of money to invest or am i looking at
this the wrong way because you're
talking about council investments i
wouldn't just explain what that what
that means
okay okay
i'll do my best um thank you chair um so
yeah i mean essentially the council
holds cash balances um it doesn't
necessarily mean that all of those cash
balances are available um for the
council to do what it wants um with we
obviously have obligations in terms of
paying you know our wage bill our
suppliers our precept payments for
example
but at any one point in time we are
generally holding a level of um cash
which um we obviously can't just hold in
our our bank account so we need to do
something with that money um in terms of
how we invest the money that's um agreed
um through this committee in terms of
our investment strategy and what kind of
investments the council is willing to
participate in and the duration of those
investments so when we set the treasury
management strategy at the beginning of
the year that sets those out and then on
a day-to-day basis um officers will make
decisions in terms of um
yeah what are available and what um
counterparties are available to invest
in which meet with that strategy
and would
deliver the best return available at
that point so
um
yeah does that answer your question yeah
so in other words at the moment at the
moment then we've got 22 million pounds
worth of
uh cash if you like invested in
something that we fit right i understand
yeah
thank you very much
councillor foster
thank you chairman um following on from
councillor dre's
questions
on the hard soft infrastructure reserve
and i understand the world reserve but
that 1.49 million was that intended was
there behind that some kind of spending
plan was there a hard soft project that
was supposed to be spent on and if there
were
what happened to them in the sense that
we hadn't spent any of that money
and the second one again following
council dre is on the s106
that's right we did get a report in july
i think we were told it would be updated
quarterly
and i haven't seen anything since the
july version
thank you
thank you
would you like me to repeat that
right it was a two-part question
perhaps i could shout louder than the
mic but that's another story right on
the hard soft infrastructure reserve my
question was
1.491 million was
reserved
was that with
spending in particular projects in mind
and if so what happened to those
projects given we didn't spend any or
was it just a reserve that's supposed to
stay as a reserve if not needed the
second one was on the s-106 it was
presented to us in july as a report
and i think we were told it would be
updated quarterly
so
i haven't seen an update since july
thank you
um yeah thank you chair uh
so yeah um as mentioned earlier the hard
stuff infrastructure reserve was
specifically set aside with the
intention of financing the asset
delivery programme so the figure that's
included there was the initial estimate
of the asset delivery program costs that
were to be funded this year um as i say
because those haven't been incurred
that's why there's the variation in in
the spend noted in the table so it was
for a specific purpose
um in relation to the section 106 monies
um yeah i did have a quick word with the
officer who's brought forward the report
previously um yeah i think the intention
originally was to do them quarterly i
think um
that may still be the case although i
know obviously it would be another one
due kind of about now um i think the
reality is that there's um usually um
not a huge amount of change within a
three-month period so probably what will
happen with um obviously um executives
agreement it would be better to bring it
back every six months but i think we
will seek to just confirm that outside
of the meeting and obviously give you an
update at the next executive meeting
okay thank you
okay thank you members no one else is
indicating so
oh sorry
council smith
thank you chairman um
not intended as a rebuked council of
wilkinson at all just as a general
comment but we do hold treasury
management training once a year the last
one was 14th of september and only five
members attended so and that that is
refreshed on an annual basis so there is
the opportunity for for members and and
starters and obviously not just yourself
to find out the wider details of
treasury management
um
as members can hear the the vast
majority of treasury management is
delegated to officers because it is
specialist knowledge that is required it
is specialist advice that is undertaken
and it is decisions that are taken on a
day-by-day basis so it's it
absolutely wouldn't be appropriate for
for members to discuss in a forum the
the precise nature of investments but
through our treasury management strategy
we do provide the strategic overview of
of what we do
the one thing that the report can't do
and i think the one thing that naomi
can't do
is at the top of the report
talk about a very successful
implementation of our treasury
management and a very positive implement
um series of actions to
to to to manage the council's
finances you could say perhaps that is
subjective and if i am subjective uh
being subjective so be it but i do
believe that our mid-year treasury
management review reflects the
successful implementation the very
successful implementation of this policy
in very challenging circumstances thank
you
there's no further
indications
just the one thing to to to to add is
that having said that i must obviously
now
give due credit to naomi and a team
hopefully on your behalf for the work
that they've done and the report thank
you
thank you
members there is one recommendation set
out at paragraph 9 of the report
which i will move from the chair
that the contents of this treasury
management mid-year report be
recommended to council
members do i have a seconder
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
okay
i think that
that was unanimous so that set his path
we now move on to item 7 which is
one that is of particular interest to
this committee
which is the um
review
by the incentive for governance and
scrutiny it's the scrutiny improvement
review and i would like to invite angela
law
assistant director legal and democratic
to introduce the report
thank you chairman
so the purpose of this report is to
update
members on the
center for governance and scrutiny
improvement review and consider the next
steps
overview and scrutiny committees were
introduced in 2000 as part of an of the
new executive arrangements to ensure
that members
of an authority who are not part of the
executive could hold the executive to
account
for the decisions and actions that
affect their communities
overview and security committees have
powers to scrutinize decisions
that the executive is planning to take
those it plans to implement and those
that have already been taken or
implemented recommendations following
scrutiny enable improvements between
major policies and how they are
implemented
overview and scrutiny committees play a
valuable role in developing policy
for this council in 2019 the local
government association peer review was
undertaken which examined
the council as a whole and identified
key areas for improvement
within these areas performance for the
overview and scrutiny function was
highlighted as a concert calls for
concern with the following statement
made the council also needs to
strengthen the scrutiny function which
members says does not play a positive
role in policy development
the peer review proposed that the center
for governance of scrutiny undertake
work with the voucher district council
to work with members and officers to
ensure that the overview and scrutiny
function is working effectively and to
develop actions to help the function
improve
the work of the
center for governance and scrutiny to
audit and review the review committee
had been postponed up until
this period due to the impact and
repercussions of the pandemic which
began shortly after the complete
completion of the peer review
this work commenced in july
2021 and involved the center of
governance of scrutiny undertaking a day
of on-site meetings with members and
officers observing recordings of
previous review committee meetings and
reviewing key documents
the draft letter was then socialized
with officers the chairman vice chairman
of review the leader and deputy leader
for the initial observations
on the 9th of november an informal
meeting was held with
the center of for governance and
scrutiny and members of the review
committee and the executive to discuss
the reports and its recommendations to
seek any feedback from members as to its
conclusions and its context
the next step is for the review
committee to develop an action plan that
will
develop and meet the recommendations of
that letter
at this point chairman i'd like to hand
over to you
thank you before i ask members for their
contributions and there's a couple of
points that i would like to make
the purpose of the review that was
undertaken is to improve the work of our
committee
and it's ultimately there to improve the
development of policy within the council
for the benefit of our residents
and the recommendations in the review i
believe are all achievable but they
will require
careful planning and commitment from the
people involved
i see this year as a as really as a
transition year to our new ways of
working because obviously we have to
develop the new the new um
protocols um
but
i i think that this will allow us to see
how we want to be operating
in the future so from the next municipal
year definitely everything should be
in place and it was mentioned at the
presentation from ian parry that really
we should be trying to be like a
parliamentary select committee in as
much as that were apolitical and that
we're there to hold the executive to
account and the report has got some good
ideas about how we can undertake that
um
one of the record of one of the
recommendations is the establishment of
a working group and i'm pleased to say
that a number of members have indicated
that they wish to be involved so
obviously myself and council mrs
mcpherson will be on the working group
but councillor dre councillor hoy
councillor myers councillor mrs
gadsden and council mrs gooding have all
indicated that they would like to be
part of the group
and that gives us seven
members which is probably the ideal
number but if if anyone else indicates
that they would like to be a member
please let me know but i don't expect it
to be is 39 councillors on the working
group because we won't actually get
anything done
so
that's my contribution so questions
council mrs shaw please
easy on
thank you
thank you chairman i was at the
presentation on the 9th 11th and i found
it very very informative and i this is
more of a statement i do apologize um
and i hope we as
with what you've just said we can move
forward and do a far better scrutiny
thank you
thank you jeff
i've got um
two observations really from the report
um it was really interesting to read
and it's it's really good to see the
recommendations from the peer review
actually in action now because otherwise
this report wouldn't have happened so
it's really positive to see
um
it's
the one the two things that stuck out
for me from the report were the first
one was about forward thinking forward
looking
um which i think is really important
because my only experience of this is my
second year on this committee my own
experience of this has been pretty much
what most people is which is noting
stuff that's been coming through which
is one of the one of the criticisms and
it's really positive to see
that there's this recommendation and i
really embrace that i think how we can
do that and it's not
it's not
it's the way the way i suppose this
blends into the two things really
because this really i know this is a
political committee but this isn't
shouldn't be the opportunity for us to
bash people
using a big political stick because i
don't think that's particularly helpful
um at the same time we are holding the
executive to account but we are all
holding the executive to account in a
constructive way
and and i think that if we look at some
of the projects that have been ongoing
through the council and are
in the future gonna be going through the
council had they gone through this
committee then they may have ended up in
a slightly different way and and i use
as an example only and not making any
political mileage whatsoever i'll assure
you about but if we look at the asset
delivery program for example
had that gone through this committee
in the way in which this report is
suggesting perhaps it should have done
or what projects that size should have
done
then i wonder if we would be in the
situation we're in now where we've had
to go back and we're now you know
because we didn't listen to public
engagement there wasn't public
engagement sooner et cetera et cetera
so
i think it's a really positive thing
that projects this size and i know at
the group leaders meeting last night the
minority group leaders meeting last
night it was suggested with
jonathan that for example the
partnership working with brentwood
council is coming up in january and
we've asked for that to come to this
committee in a draft format as well
which is fully um willing to do so those
are the sort of things that i i think
are really positive the second second
thing really is is the the report talks
about trust
um and and and that really is a huge
thing and i think if we're all honest
with each other i think that's one thing
that's lacking between the members is
trust
um and and i i can see the reasons why
from both sides of the fence
um but i think if we're to move forward
on this then that trust needs to be
rebuilt i don't
profess to have the answers but i would
like chairman if i may
to make recommendation that perhaps
when the when the terms of reference for
the working group are formulated
that perhaps
certainly members could give some
consideration as to how
we can rebuild trust and i see that as a
duty of
um not just the working group but the
four group leaders all of whom we're all
in here tonight and also all 39 members
of this council
but i i think that's an important thing
and those are the two point two big
things that stuck out for me from the
report thank you
thank you council mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman
councillor wilkinson makes some very
fair points
and what he and looking around i think
80 or 90 of this committee won't realize
is that the review committee used to be
very robust and very effective and it
has
lost its way in future years in recent
years and
i think this report
reflects where we are and we need to
build back from that
i would urge you a couple of words of
caution i think we need to be careful as
a review committee to review
just analyze
to scrutinize
and to recommend and not to carry out
the portfolio holders and the executive
work i think there is a danger there
that sometimes
there is a blend of that and in the
recent years there was a situation where
this committee almost ended up doing a
portfolio holder's role
that said this is constructive it's
helpful and it would be very good if
instead of us seeing completed reports
that we then have to call in
and try and change that we saw if we saw
draft reports
and the draft reports we could then
comment
and analyze and give constructive
criticism
so that those reports
benefit the whole council and not just
part of the council so i do welcome this
and i would certainly be willing to go
on the working group i assumed that that
would be sorted out tonight but if the
chairman feels that seven is adequate
i'm quite happy not to go on there i
don't want to handicap the council
anyway
so thank you mr chairman and
hopefully we will improve with this
reports implementation
thanks councilman mrs mason although
seven is the ideal number one more is uh
always welcome so uh
thank you i'd be happy to uh if you want
to be part of the working group and
please feel free to join
can i just ask have we got
representatives of all
the groups on your working group because
i think it would be helpful if that was
the situation i know you read out a list
of names but i'm afraid i didn't absorb
them
well the answer to that is no but i did
i did
send an email out to every single
counsellor asking them if they wish to
be on the group okay
yes i think i certainly read it that we
would be formulating that at this
meeting i didn't realize it was having
to be done before yeah so perhaps others
made the same error but uh okay that's
fine so we haven't okay it's a shame but
never mind
but council dray
thank you chairman can you hear me
um
chairman um i fully agree with all of
your recommendations and i look forward
to being an active member of the working
group
the review committee should be much more
involved in projects from day one when
we can offer offers officers
and or the executive independent advice
and scrutiny
our work should concentrate far more on
scrutiny than on review
thank you chairman
thank you
um before we go on to the
recommendations um i invited the leader
of the councillor
along because i see the work that we're
going to be involved in here is a
partnership between our committee
and the executive and i'd just like to
invite councilwood just to say
how he sees this work going for from the
executive point of view
so
thank you chairman um
and uh
thank you very much indeed the uh
it's quite a um
a challenge isn't it to review review
and quite a bold step
for the authority to actually sort of
say how can we actually do things
uh better
certainly the briefing in early november
was extremely helpful
so that
mr parry was able to go through his
report in detail
and as has already been said
the principle of review and actually i
happen to think the name review is
rather wishy-washy i think it should be
about scrutiny i think it should be
about holding the
administration to account
and actually strengthening along the way
the executive relationship with review
i believe
it is about driving continuous
improvement
and i think it is also about and as
councillor wilkinson alluded to
actually bringing reports
in advance of the formal governance
process to review to scrutiny to be
scrutinized to be challenged
so that
we as the administration are held to
account
and i think the asset delivery program
would have been good if it had gone
through this process
i think
certainly the brentwood partnership
going to review in advance of coming to
a council meeting will be
good because it means that by the time
it does conclude its path
hopefully we end up with a report
which is stronger and has had challenge
along the way rather than reaching
the council meeting
where
there are perhaps still some very
reasonable questions to be tested
so i welcome this approach chairman um i
fully endorse the approach that is being
taken in this paper tonight of setting
up a working group and i would like to
complement and congratulate all members
on taking this bold step to strengthen
the scrutiny process i certainly support
it welcome the review welcome the
outcome and all the recommendations
thank you chairman
members there are two recommendations
which are set out at paragraph nine on
the report
and they are
which i will move from the chair so
first of all do i do i have a um a
seconder
that's right
thank you and so the first one is that
the contents of the final report letter
dated november 2021 by the center for
governance and scrutiny improvement
review be noted as set out at appendix 1
to this report is that noted members
thank you
the second is that a member working
group of the review committee be set up
to develop an action plan to deliver the
recommendations of the centre for
governance and scrutiny can those
members in favour please raise their
hands
okay
thank you thank you that was unanimous
thank you members chairman if i may um
just to confirm
um the members of your working group the
names please
um which is the chair yourself
counselor mrs mcpherson councillor dre
councillor hoy councillor myers
councillor gadsden
councillor mrs goodin and councillor mrs
mason yeah
councilman smithson
come on
thank you
the wonders of sector
meant to make things faster
um
just one thing i'd like to request that
the dates that this working group are
meeting are notified in advance well in
advance and perhaps set at the outset
because recently the council have given
us two days notice three days notice of
meetings and members are particularly
busy and i'm sure we would like to
attend if we have adequate notice then
the majority of us will probably will be
able to attend if we're given very short
notice it's going to be very difficult
for us so can i make that request please
mr chairman
thanks yeah certainly what i propose to
do or what my idea is that
i'll put together a sort of calendar of
events and circulate that probably by
the end of this week and that will give
the dates well into the future then when
we're going to have our meetings
thank you yes thank you
now move on to item 8 which is the key
decisions document and as usual i'll go
through the table a line at a time
so on page 2 of the key decisions
document
reference 0 four stroke two one the
voluntary sector grant allocations
twenty twenty two to twenty three
okay no one indicating thank you
also on page two
zero nine stroke two one which is the
ripper policy and ripper social media
guide
okay no one indicating thank you
on page three eleven stroke two one the
compulsory purchase of land at michelin
farm raleigh
that's not indicating
on a game on page 312 stroke 21 the
report of the project stroke program
management office
again no one indicating
13 stroke 21 which is the south essex
parking partnership
councillor mrs mason
thank you i'd just like to ask some
questions on this and i don't know if
there's anyone here that can answer them
i read it says new proposed new working
arrangements for a new term of the
partnership agreement
i've not noticed or seen anything about
this
and it is a
controversial
agreement
and i wonder if we're going to be
consulted or if that's something that we
can look at
before it's actually the decision is
made or is it something that's going to
be automatically done
by the administration
thank you chairman through you uh if you
i'm happy to answer that question
um the uh the report is due to come to
the executive it says on the
key decisions document therefore it
isn't an automatic decision
in relation to the proposed partnership
agreement it relates to the terms of
reference of the joint committee
therefore i would expect that
documentation to be available
through youtube i can ask the portfolio
holder to provide a written response to
mrs council mrs mason's question
thank you
moving on to item nine
which is um the work plan
and
members are there any questions on the
work panel or any observation
on the work plan
sorry councilman did you indicate no
i'll show you i'm just wiping my hands
after
moving the mic
as instructed
no one is indicating so that is the um
sorry
i'm right on the other side of your
blind spot
germany if i can perhaps um talk to the
meeting of the 11th of january
um
council wilkinson mate has already made
reference to the
potential for the um
arrangements for the proposed
partnership between this authority and
brentwood borough council
to come to this venue ahead of any
decision by the exec sorry by fall
council in in falls of time um and
through you chair i proposed that um the
the work plan accommodate that uh on the
11th of january meeting
thanks that's fine
i'm writing it so yes it will be okay
okay the worst thing is when you set
yourself a target and then you can't
achieve it so
that's great
right no one else has indicated so that
is the final agenda item so the meeting
is closed at
2016.
thank you members
and just just as a reminder the
book of condolence is at the front here
thank you